la folie du patin à roulettes qui gagne
aujourd'hui le centre de new york
avec au coeur de central park une piste
d'entraînement réservée aux patineurs
sur fond de musique disco bien
évidemment
m
il y aurait aujourd'hui 28 millions
d'américains qui seraient devenus des
adeptes inconditionnels de ce nouveau
sport
et
b
officiellement on appelle ça le roller
skate mais on dit généralement le rôle
ère où le skate
alors restons français et parlons
simplement du patin à roulettes
il revient à la mode il revient en force
pendant la période de noël
il s'en est vendu comme des petits pains
on a retrouvé une paire de patins datant
de 1860
il ne s'agit donc pas d'une nouveauté
sont les enfants cela leur permet de
renouveler leur jeu de se dépenser
physiquement d'être en plein air un
bilan donc positif
des commerçants avisés ont ainsi dû
s'ouvrir des perspectives rentable
exemple ce dancing à la porte de paris
c'est le seul établissement de ce genre
existantes actuellement en france
et ça marche ou plutôt ça roule alors
une mode
parions plutôt pour une nouvelle
activité de loisir une des rares notons
le au passage à ne pas consommer de
pétrole